de nouveaux succès en vue pour l'armée
ukrainienne d'après plusieurs
témoignages elle semble encore gagner du
terrain cette fois dans le sud mais
c'est véritablement dans le don vaste en
l'est que l'avancée la plus
significative le week-end dernier qui a
va libérer la ville de Liman on retrouve
notre envoyé spécial en Ukraine
Gwendoline de Bono
la prise de Limone est à la fois un
succès militaire pour qui aime mais
c'est également un succès politique
puisque les troupes russes ont battu en
traite
le Poutine signé l'annexion de la région
de Donetsk à la Russie et la ville de
Liman est située dans cette région de
Doni est-ce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on voit des troupes des
troubles ukrainiennes qui continuent sur
leur lancée qui continue à attaquer et
qui est bien grignote les routes de
communication dont se servent les Russes
les routes de ravitaillement mais
également les ne ferroviaires nous
discutions avant-hier avec un commandant
des Forces Spéciales ukrainiennes qui
nous lisaient et bien qu'il poursuivait
la contre-offensive à lancer début
septembre et qu'il pouvait la poursuivre
et bien parce qu'aujourd'hui les
Ukrainiens disposent de l'initiative et
des meilleures positions pour pour
attaquer c'est vrai qu'on voit des
troupes russes qui ont le plus grand mal
à tenir l'intégralité du front elles ont
le plus grand mal à organiser des lignes
de défense et puis selon des sources
militaires les biens les troupes russes
sont en train de reculer également sur
le front sud dans la région de Carson à
double Vladimir Poutine a décidé
également l'annexion à la Russie